i've done an entire episode um
on uh valuetainment economics called
should you rent or buy there it is i
don't know can you even see this uh you
can see that boom boom you can see that
i'm holding up paper and if you google
rent or buy
you're going to have 100 different
answers 100 different answers
buy of course it's a great investment
you should be doing it home mortgage
it's at the bed rates are so low now's
the time and then you're gonna have 100
different other articles that are saying
renting is the way to go have roommates
save that money
enjoy flexibility have mobility you got
to figure out your situation
ren buying is a is a sham it's a
lifestyle choice it's not an investment
right right so you know there's a
difference between buying a house with a
mortgage and making payments versus an
investment property okay there's a big
difference with yeah grant cardone talks
about that okay i'm not a huge grant
cardone guy but i do respect the fact
that he's in big in commercial real
estate reits is fun with that but he
rents
he runs so here's my here's here's my
point if you're young let me just
actually even read what i said here so
you should rent if here's when you
should rent or if you should buy it's a
little uh a little um
who do you want to be right what kind of
lifestyle you should rent if
you appreciate mobility flexibility and
freedom of movement being able to come
and go as you please and move from place
to place as opportunities arise if
you're unsure of your next moves of your
next five moves pbd shout out right
there and if you're gonna change your
mind well i might live in miami while i
might actually move to new york or i
don't know la's kind of cool but people
are moving to austin don't buy you don't
even know where the hell you're gonna
live okay
short term if you're not sure where
you're gonna be for the next three five
years short term just
rent
just rent okay
career changes for sure if you're gonna
have a career change who knows i might
be working here i might be over there i
might be working on this company i might
i don't know
just rent it's cool it's all good if you
have roommates if you're young enough
like 40 years old i'm not trying to have
a roommate right now bro like i'm trying
to find a wife at some point right i've
been married briefly but you know next
phase of my life
can't bring a you know a potential wife
that is my roommate
david over here yeah not a good look um
but if you're young 20 25 even up to 30
i think 30 sort of a cutoff right there
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
over 30.
you can split the cost of rent bro yeah
what's wrong with that and and and
from a financial perspective if you
already have high debt student loans
like we talked about here
credit card car loans consumer debt
everything
now you want to go take out another 250
000 in debt for a mortgage
who should buy though so those are the
people that should not buy whatsoever
straight up i'm telling you right now
you should buy if you're stable secure
and you're stationary you ain't going
nowhere i'm here for the long haul
whether you're stuck or whether you
choose to be yeah uh stuck is a
different story so if you know exactly
where you want to be
and you want to take pride in ownership
this is where i live this is my block
this is my neighborhood hell yeah you
should buy yeah right
okay long term we talked about short
term with renting long term i'm going to
be here for at least 5 ten years i know
that i'm locked in i'm not going
anywhere because a lot of times the
first few years you're paying off
amortization rates we talked about that
fees uh everything that starts like you
haven't even tapped into paying off the
principal of your mortgage yet all right
if you've got a family you're settled
down you got kids schools taxes stuff
like that
yeah maybe you should uh should look
into buying that's an option for you
right sense of community you want to be
in the neighborhood and if you don't
have a lot of debt already if you want
to save up and especially you want to
have a four saving plans to have in your
mortgage uh not a bad idea the point
point is this different strokes for
different folks bro
not everyone it's not a cookie cutter
approach your renter should you buy
figure it out anyway there's a couple of
um tips for you right there
so
what i like about renting what i've done
what has made me a freaking millionaire
is high flexibility low overhead low
overhead right so i keep all right i
know that i'm making x amount a year if
i if i'm making 100 grand a year i know
that the maximum amount of rent that i
should pay in a year is 30 that's 30
thousand dollars so 30 000
divided by 12 i don't know was that 2500
bucks something like that so
that's my number i know that that's what
i can spend in rent all right so the
problem that people don't understand is
when they buy a mortgage it's not just
the mortgage payment
you've got other factors in there what i
call the big three expenses of a
mortgage or buying you've got your
maintenance
you've got insurance and you've got
taxes those things are factored in the
point is this yeah i went on a rant
there bro where's the button i went on a
rant what's your point
the realtor associates has done a great
job of convincing people that renting is
throwing away money and there
go is money
all you
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro